lindsey perlman has died she was 43
years old maybe now it's time for a
selena the actress was known for her
many tv roles including general hospital
and selena the series
lindsay's body was found in hollywood on
sunday near the popular hiking trail
runyon canyon the lapd confirmed her
death in a statement shared to their
website pearlman's cousin savannah also
confirmed the news on friday writing on
twitter quote i am deeply sad to report
that they have found lindsay and it was
too late i have no other information
about the location or circumstance law
enforcement released this missing person
sheet on wednesday
no further details about pearlman's
cause of death has been shared in the
initial missing persons alert on
february 13th the lapd said she quote
failed to return to home
several tributes for the late actress
were shared on social media ghost
actress danielle pinnock took to twitter
calling pearl men quote hilarious
stunning and ridiculously gifted friend
and fellow actress lynn chin posted this
photo of pearlman and her dog she wrote
this is how i will remember lindsey
pearlman i am so sorry to her family and
all the communities who deeply adored
her
lindsay's career also included roles on
chicago justice and american housewife
manubrium's part of the sternum so
someone hit him in the chest someone or
something
actor john ceta seen here acting
alongside pearlman on chicago justice
wrote in part on twitter quote lindsay
was so talented and an absolute dream to
work with so saddened by her loss
i think
there's a lesson in there somewhere
frank valentini an executive producer
for general hospital also shared his
memory of lindsay to social media he
tweeted quote lindsey pearlman was
terrific on general hospital and we are
saddened to hear of this tragedy our
hearts go out to her family and friends
you